what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are about to kick off
our reactions for Henry cavill's last
season of The Witcher
um I'm not as excited as I would like to
be mainly because I'm aware the best
part of the show is leaving yeah it's
hard to yeah cope with that yeah but
it's his last season so I figured why
not just go in with like an open mind
obviously and uh have a little bit of a
Bittersweet experience I suppose and uh
hopefully uh it ends up being really
enjoyable that's my best wish I'm not
going in here to be like hyper critical
or something like that we even liked the
season that a lot of people didn't like
which was season two so it's by no means
a thing about the show it's just the
fact that Henry Cavill is leaving which
has made the experience a bit dejecting
is all but
let's be professional
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
toss a coin to the like button also
subscribe click that notification Bell
to get notified when I react for the
next episode of The Witcher is up here
on this channel this is the first
episode so uh you know usually full
introduction watch laundry stick it with
your own copy available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page but because
it's the first episode that one is made
public and so if you want to sync up
watch along with us uh there's a link in
the description box and pin comments so
you don't need to pledge to our patreon
page for the first episode so please
just go ahead and use that if you'd like
Anyway let's see what this episode is
like
we're seeking a girl and a Witcher
masterians will recompense you
handsomely for illumination as to their
whereabouts because he's a fire guy
looking for me
[Music]
dude
ah damn look at that CGI blood
it's gotten better it's got more weight
to it I am petunia
um
it's like out of a video game
nice that head fell incredibly
gracefully to the ground
for your discretion thank you I will not
count this
anything helps I will do everything in
my power to help Siri grow her magical
skill it's going to be a long road ahead
for all of us
your friend Jennifer I'm officially in
the friend zone dear friend she has
great potential but little Talent
it's okay she mastered The Witcher
course
Knows My Name
wow I mean it's not like you burned
their actual home down yeah I mean you
could probably repurpose this place
pretty easily I could have just left it
let it be
for your discretion I will not count it
anything helps any little Satchel of
coin I assume is plenty the honor System
is what we abide by this is Trope of
these kind of fantasy movies and shows
I've always loved would never counted
people know the weight of the right
amount of coin
dear friend it seems that you and Syria
thoroughly enjoying our fourth house in
as many months finding time to bond so
delightfully
I will remind you though that you asked
nay begged me to teach her magic uh-oh
someone's starting to become bitter I'm
Eric
Siri taketh away
[Music]
slaughter them Siri tell yennefer we're
leaving
[Laughter]
and I expect payment for my discretion
just any Satchel will do just let me
hear the sound of the coins we're good
we're so far off the map here that we
may never leave again
we'll continue magic lessons before the
ice melts I promise but for now perhaps
the girl deserves a break
just having fun with me now so it's okay
I've been wanting to invite me to dinner
ever since we arrived
yeah bye
no but I look through your window and
you have more wine and I'm begging for
really far isn't it girls fill it with
your urine dear friend that's not wine
you're drinking
yeah
look at them oh it's like when families
on the edge are divorce during covid
finally managed to make things work
got no choice otherwise
[Music]
I am enjoying this simplistic bonding of
them before things becoming crazy you
know convoluted plots
before all the plot lines converge
prophecies
automatic is tricky that's what you said
about Earth Magic and air magic what do
you have power like nothing I've seen I
think so hard for both of us try fire
how could Fire magic be any worse with
Fire magic the source is you
take something you never get back your
magic
yes oh a built-in festival's just down
the valley you should come I'd love to
it's not a bad idea and everyone will be
in costume what could go wrong
oh my fresh Chum for you
now see how you like my new pets
whoa that one hurt that jacket pace is
trying to smell your kind from a league
away then I've come to the right place
uh I need to find a girl with Elven
blood oh my Japanese is a sense I'll do
you one better
oh is that the same actor I can't tell
is that Liam Hemsworth
she is out of there
have there been sightings or are we
chasing more rumors we don't know yeah
Galadriel I will find dobathana but how
there is no Sanctuary left for elves
here all the become clear once we have
cerrilla she is our new hope
Siri you could unite everything
he doesn't need you to play nurse maid
he needs you to play Soldier
Medics Are Soldiers too is that Robbie
Amell he looked familiar maybe
the whole continent is our doorbell we
tried sharing the continent for
centuries if there's to be another
genocide this time it'll be the humans
don't worry global warming is gonna take
care of everything
you promised me a princess you swore
cirilla would be mine perhaps a tad go
out to your highness we wouldn't want
your beloved to catch wind
our attention has been diverted because
of the squirrels oh yeah more excuses
they're blaming us for murdering that
stupid elephant baby
it definitely wasn't ours
a spymaster who can't find one girl now
it's time for exchange
right of it what's that
this is gonna go great as for Prince
seed waste
all departure
I'm not gonna order someone to babysit
the prince while he flits about looking
to the girl we don't trust anyone else
we're actually gonna see this guy's
personality a little more yeah
if I do this
I'll be the only one giving orders when
I get back
this will definitely help differentiate
from his house of the Dragon character
what do you think
I think you need to hide your hair and
mask your eyes would it kill you to say
you look lovely
you look like a no daughter of mine my
name's got a bad idea
oh you look hot you're so hot
[Music]
it looks lovely
nice let's do some Eyes Wide Shut look
at what happens when we let her have one
good night
let's not pretend your motivations
aren't Italian selfish Jennifer happy
birthday to you too
oh you do care say you remember our good
night
after the gin
season one call back
the overnight carriage ride from
ellender to Moen
the Beltane Festival
in the mornings they were lonely
you're often left before Dawn oh you did
but then one time girls did remember you
guys remember
scared what would happen if we really
tried
I was unsure it was actually what I
wanted not just some trick of the Jen's
Magic
and now I
[Music]
oh these always go well never turns into
a psychological nightmare yeah you're
not gonna have some kind of vision in
here
hahaha
[Laughter]
cut through the hedges man
it is it's like a big old monster pill
bug yeah
damn
[Music]
raining paid off
damn
strength
catch it in a magic jar
staying at the right spot squelch
intensifies we draw him out we give him
the thing he wants most
you have a caravan leaving tomorrow
don't you I want to go with you but it's
important that no one knows that for us
this plan isn't going to work tell me
what I need to do get her on the care of
it
without the listening
we need you to complain about the
spoiled brat who ruined belting for
everyone now I have to hold that Ava
brat Palace all the way to Aiden with my
Caravan
no
they'll know who you're talking about
you think this Mage is going to believe
that you let Siri raid with an escort
she'll be traveling with someone we
trust seemingly innocuous oh come on yes
yes my man
is what we do my sweet we are creatives
free thinkers All is fair
I am doing everything that I can we
invested a lot in your operations and
we've gotten nothing in return deeksha
and I are ready to cut you loose what is
this new or am I forgetting something
like what did you fall in with them look
at me look at my eyes there is no need
to harm the innocent
that's it
this guy's not so bad oh cirilla girl
has enemies everywhere
is not a bad place humid in the summer
but the food is spectacular oh he's
actually good at his job yeah so far you
could be a robot
no no a stayed life at court is not for
me if your time at court has been stayed
you've been doing it wrong dang
it's a persuasive guy deliver the girl
or we will single-handedly undo Every
Good Deed you have done for the elves
you
five days and I remember helping the
elves this season feels so much more
modern yeah yeah even in some of the
ways they talk and stuff yeah
your friends need help
of course they do
it's a tight spot alaran
Brave and inspiring Elven Warrior who
thought she could defeat the humans she
was wrong
they always are after the conjunction
humans arrived the elves thought the
humans were just a nuisance sure but
they would die off in the blink of an
Elven eye but the humans kept
multiplying as we do like a disease
sounds like she thought what she
believed in she did fight for what she
believed in she let those young and
passionate elves to war
at this place this is where they fought
of how much of a father he's become yeah
gotta fat you up need you back out there
food goes to the ones who fought all
elves share equally
otherwise we're no better than the
humans we are socialists
it seems like this guy is going to be
starting his own faction of elves ask
where tail forces should be United what
did you see out there to change your
mind I simply had time to consider your
position
[Music]
three
you two really think I'm that shitty of
a god
another dream
sleep thinking about Halloran and my
grandmother burned with the exact same
mission
looking off for something different
a way forward that doesn't divide but
unites
exactly
I understand both because I am both and
that is my strength yes yes I have the
power to change the cycle of hatred
and I want to
because I am sick and tired of
Destruction and loss
I don't doubt you Siri
I too doubt the world though
it
requires an action yes it's just one big
action scene out there I got so much
more Hands-On and affectionate yeah it's
meant to be a father she can do this
[Music]
hey
I've brought more friends this time
you could do this Siri remember your
Witcher training stormy my magic
foreign
[Music]
that frame rate
I like my arms I like how old's better
go team
that's not good
are you sure you sent him to the right
place
all right good
we just need to wait for goat
oh
no
hey oh what's up team
oh no
Dara
so she's always been so badass
I don't look so special yeah just hurt
my feelings
[Laughter]
feel that one
you call yourself an elf she's a quarter
elf she belongs with me
damn your Majors out of her death
where'd his sword go
use it
[Music]
preventing him from being able to do
stuff now yeah
oh oh nice
oh sweet oh my God this is great the way
the way he moves
[Music]
wow
wow that was great choreography
that cavel
whoa yeah
dang I hope you got to eat before that
you'll be fine
your loots on the other hand
has seen better days
it's okay
isn't the only Rogue mate we're dealing
with someone very powerful is puppeting
him I need help oh
I can talk to you no you don't know how
difficult it is to embody power but not
have access to it going to aratuza
cannot be the only answer it's the best
thing for her
is it or for you yes
I need to finally answer to finish him
off
I can't go with you
and we can't go with you
France just feels like a nuisance and
not much of a threat yeah
figure for for all the build up lessons
it just seems kind of like a guy who
shows up to get in your way Tennessee
lost her brother and I have lost a dozen
more she lied to us
as I wonder
we need her everyone needs her she
brings nothing but death the problem
isn't her
that's that one
I've had enough where are you going to
get help from an old friend I have no
idea who he could be referring to who
haven't we seen yet
I've got her
yeah and I say this isn't goodbye for
good
that there are more good nights to come
yes that you will
of me
that's my problem to you
no a new excuse this time I'll do it
serious in danger
and so the people around her it would be
best she landed somewhere safe nowhere
is safe
Mage with a fondness for fire brilliant
get rid of them you will have earned
series Trust
and girls
and might in that order you're good at
this game
if you say sick babe
yes
odd character
dear friend I wrote you but you still
ain't calling
[Laughter]
should I say we
sides are a Tuesday is not to her liking
I have my eyes on our next home
a dollhouse on a squid Farm
oh yes
friend
and left after all those good nights
because I was scared
for the first time
I understand real fear oh his hair is
very dry for that rain
I'm just uncertain on this continent
oh I will learn to trust you again
you Siri and I
We Belong Together
finally
oh boy
no
cherish her memory
just wants his daughter I know
[Music]
and he burned those screenshots from
season one
hey
well
um
that's cool
yeah yeah that's cool or or back in the
world doing stuff feels like a part
three it does see yeah that's a good way
to put that it's got a little bit of a
different way of moving it's got a
little bit of different way of speaking
and it's trying to like hit you real
quick with a whole bunch of stakes don't
let people get bored yeah don't let
people get bored yeah speed it up this
is so fast paced like for Witcher
standards especially yeah this was so
fast yeah yeah and after at least the
first kind of Chunk where you're like
living with them for a little bit and
even though it's hopping through time
and places they're living like At first
you're like okay I'm kind of getting
into the and then like once things
really pop off it's like wow you're just
getting everybody back in the game yeah
yeah yeah even we're at like ultimate
because they split this up into two two
parts
which I'm not sure what the purpose was
for that
um
so I thought it'd be even slower yeah
when you do something like that but this
was so it's just so quick and like think
about everything that I can't even
possibly recap every single thing that
happened in here
um but yeah that it was really the
pacing was it was the most jarring part
to me because the writing and the
dialogue seemed so much more modern than
before and I know those they were
already like kind of transitioning there
with season two
where it was feeling more accessible
because I remember season one it was a
little bit of a okay
trying to like brain on him notes
pretend you're reading it there's a lot
to keep up with here
um and then season two that did make it
easier to digest and um you know just
keep up with what's happening but here
it was like I kind of likened some of
the experience of this too how I was
feeling with Mandalorian season three oh
this is really fast and it's it's more
fun it's a lot more action uh
and I didn't
I I I still enjoyed it though I don't
want to just seem like I'm I'm just
dogging on it to dog on it or something
I I still enjoyed it for the most part
uh the the
the acting still good they're the
um I like I like that's Rafael I just
gotta look that up right yeah yeah go
look it up yeah it looked pretty sure
and when he showed up I was like wait a
minute like yeah he looks super familiar
yeah so uh and Witcher have you type
that in yeah you know I don't know I
wouldn't be surprised we're gonna get
the Liam Hemsworth treatment soon for
Robbie seems like he would be just just
as easy to slide in on the heels of an
announcement like that oh yeah let me
see here it was Robbie melon Witcher
yeah yeah yeah he plays um Gallop yeah
he plays Gallatin is the guy's name
gotcha and then I'm going to check if
rants has been recast because that
character too like when uh yeah okay so
it is a different casting on him as well
and that character like when he showed
up in the previous I was like okay like
at the outset you're like ooh fire Mage
forbidden magic this guy's gonna be
twisted
and uh and yeah now here it kind of
feels just like ah you know he's a guy
who shows up to give us a fight once in
a while and that's about it
I mean I hope it results in something a
little bit more than that but I think
they just wanted this one to be
Swift and entertaining because I felt
like it was really devoid of tension and
Stakes the entire time which is
something Witcher really needs it really
needs that especially when the plot is
like last season ends off with everyone
wants Siri yeah that is and the reveal
of um her dad you know like all that is
it was a great ending uh for it and a
great setup
and I mean obviously it's still the plot
here yet you know by the time you get to
that finale where ever everyone shows up
that should be like intense and high
stakes yeah
and it's just sort of uh fleetingly
entertaining with some occasional cool
sort of play
you know and
I'll admit yeah it's a little bit um
it's a little bit weak to me is it
possible see there's on the weaker side
of Witcher for sure
yeah I mean it just doesn't feel as
substantial like there is I don't know
like not
they're clearly out of the position
where they feel like they have to keep
up with like the
tonal elements of like living I feel
like The Witcher show was probably at
first brought to light as you know kind
of Netflix going we need our Game of
Thrones and I feel like earlier on in
the show there was a more literary
feeling tone where it's like you would
kind of stay in a place and you would
feel its Vibes you would kind of it
doesn't feel right
no exactly it's like this feels like
actors playing dress-up now yeah they
would go a long way in earlier at least
in the first it's kind of you know it's
become yeah more blockbustery as you
know season two and now season three at
least at the start you know kind of
feels as it has gone on but yeah I feel
like you need some of those elements of
you know taking the time to live in the
world and stew in these character beats
and stuff like that because especially
for what Siri is going through I mean
yeah like they start to feel now like
the family in some kind of medieval
Adventure movie rather than you know
this fated Trio who has been you know
across so many different timelines and
and prophecies and and you know
Arrangements of fate and blah blah like
yeah now it sort of feels like well
everybody likes the three of them
together so we gotta you know like
really ride that family Dynamic and then
split them up yeah split them up so that
we have that's our tension because
that's what people want is they want
Ninja to get back to baby Yoda now and
that's that's our
but they were like they just got
we didn't re-watch it
okay they didn't all come to converge
together the three main characters until
the end of last season right yeah it was
the end of last season yeah and now
they're divided again except of course
you know yeah they have this whole thing
yeah
they're one of their locations with the
witches you know yeah sure yeah
um cool
yeah uh I I thought I liked the I
thought it was as what it really played
well on is the fact that I just I like
the performers and I like the characters
especially our three leads and I like
the world generally generally I like the
world yeah so it was mainly working off
of that like my favorite parts of it
were actually just them hanging out and
bonding and having a good time like that
that was my my favorite part is spanning
that time and the letters that those
some of my favorite parts of the of this
whole episode and seeing geralt be a lot
more
express it like he's been so stoic all
these seasons and now you could feel the
note of this season girl it's gonna be a
lot more emotionally available
he's going to open himself up now he's
the Ultimate Fantasy character he's like
you he's a totally nurturing he's Joel
from the last of the Year Dad of the
year but he can still slice people up
yeah
yeah he's really he's a lot more open
even the way how he's reserved and
standoffish towards
uh and not Syria uh Jennifer the way he
stand office towards her
uh even there it's like at least not
totally I mean look at it you know him
he's a big soft you know this is still
flirting yeah it's a little bit more
soap opera in the way they handle it
it's a lot of that that was kind of sort
of charming to me other than the the
cutesiness of it like it was way cuter
than before yeah uh
it did feel like they were this lack of
living in it and a lot of telling me
what I should be thinking and feeling
the whole time well there's just so much
more dialogue that is plot oriented and
and I mean we're joking about Recaps at
the beginning but like recap oriented
and and I just feel like yeah this was
the kind of sh it feels like every
season's at a different showrunner maybe
they have uh I don't know who the
showrunners are but each one has felt
like
it was like watching The Walking Dead
like yeah it starts to change each time
you come back and each sensibility they
approach it with and here
yeah like there's not
doesn't really feel like there was much
character meat on any of the dialogue
especially they were they were saying
stuff though to provide characters yeah
I realize now what I need is what I fear
is losing you guys and what my motion
like that's what everyone was
so I everyone had a note for what they
wanted for their character this season
and then they just said the note yes
like they don't this isn't a show so
much right now or it's not presenting as
a show that's about scenes and about
really building this lore and really you
know weaving this intricate web of
convoluted but like there's there's an
art to yeah coming up with all these you
know places and factions of people and
finding a way to get you caught up in
all of it rather than just having it be
like okay wait who are these people
again and what do they want they all
kind of wants the same mumbo jumbo thing
are they gonna kill her they got a user
um and yeah it's like this kind of felt
like okay you know we've got this
prologue that's got everything everybody
likes which is three of them and then
it's just like Hey we're gonna hit you
with like familiar characters and we're
gonna jump around and you know I feel
like this could have been a couple
episodes worth of material and let it
breathe
yeah because I was like oh this should
be a bummer that they're splitting apart
yeah and the like the things there's so
much plot happening at this point I'm
like I feel like sure you montage over
it but I don't really
it's a little Revel in the Beltane
celebration like it should be a big
moment for Siri because it is her
birthday and it is like a she has been
in hiding and feeling this angst of
having to move everywhere and as much as
I don't want it to be like a soap opera
of like you guys never let me do
anything but we have to protect you like
you know it would have been nice to
Revel in some of those feelings have
some conflict and even in that moment
where they're attacked and the big
creature shows up and then they leave
again like it still doesn't quite truly
feel like there was like a huge risk of
life or some kind of you know shattering
like damn it this was our this is what
we finally found at home yeah it just
feels like ah we gotta keep this thing
moving you know yeah yeah I don't really
like yeah I don't know what's the name
rents here uh the fire guy yeah uh rants
is what they're going with this same guy
yeah a different actor same guy same
difference yeah so it is a different
actor yeah okay
um
yeah I'm not a big fan of of of I mean I
remember liking him in season two uh but
I liked the performer no no shade to the
new actor but I did like that performer
enough to like that character it doesn't
feel threatening um at all and the
character who I did like a lot though
who which the one that surprised me is
the the brother to the king yes he was a
really nice surprise because
he is just so bored but he's that guy
who could just show up but because he's
bored he's but he's so confident in a
way that is so natural yeah because it's
a it's that confidence that stems from I
just don't care enough yeah you know
yeah
um then when he when he shows up like I
loved his introduction we were like oh
god king God is Idiot Brother on it and
then he starts talking and he asking
you're like oh never mind this guy's
like freaking amazing at what he does
he's a persuasive guy yeah yeah using
that that sort of I that whatever that
is that that like oh this guy might not
be very bright to his Advantage yeah
this like apathetic quality that he has
that was really great yeah it was the
one engrossing it was the one engrossing
character thing because they threw
somebody at you who yeah you have this
initial impression of and then over the
few scenes we get him and I was like
okay so is this guy just like smarter
and more Charming than he looks and then
at the end I'm like is this guy actually
a lot more like skeevy and depraved than
he lets on like yeah and and this I feel
like that's a type of character too who
like especially
can lend you know your pulp and your uh
like really uncomfortable so like I feel
like these shows more so than even a lot
of modern shows are populated by these
like feral people who you know can
present as you have to bored or amused
but are secretly like sick and twisted
inside and and that was the one
character where I felt like man I want
to know what's inside this guy like I
want to know who this guy really is I
was out of outside of our main Trio
whenever we cut to him I was most
interested yeah I mean I like the main
Trio because we like the main Trio and I
like yeah skier because I like yaskir
but even hear something they wrote him
like he's a fan favorite it wrote him
like a lot of the way of the writing was
in this episode was was very off to me
you see I I heard the complaint about
the writing with them not being adherent
to the source material yes
I don't know what here is accurate to
the source material
I'm talking just about General writing
right now yeah and um
that was very off to me this entire
episode uh I don't know editing and
writing was just way off to me and and
so to me that's where I was like ooh not
a good sign Henry Cavill of course is is
as awesome of a presence as always
and he's got that benefit of
he's got that the I had a brief
sometimes an actor sticks around for a
show and you could tell they're bored
and they want to leave the show and
eventually they leave the show you know
but they're just getting a paycheck
the benefit of Henry Cavill is even if
geralt looks bored you're like but that
could just be the character sure because
it's scary yeah sorry either wait I
don't I don't feel like he's not
committed I'm not I'm not saying that
it's just sometimes you have a behind
and I feel like this show this show more
than ever especially knowing that
they've already got a replacement
um and like everyone knows that you
might observe some of the performance
with that like is he still here like is
he still truly invested he seems
invested uh but uh but anytime he seems
like he's not invested I'm like they
could just be careful you know yeah yeah
no no and it's a testament to his
presence as an actor and and what he has
been able to maintain like because yeah
in a situation like that it makes me
wonder because yeah if he is bored I
think he's doing a very professional job
at it because it's still engrossing to
watch him and and I think the character
also benefits from not being the most
talkative guy so there are times when
you get to just watch him be yeah yeah
um but at the same time yeah I mean part
of me wonders about the recasting part
of me wonder
you know just looking at this and then
looking at stuff from before I feel like
I could fathom how as an actor you might
be less enthused about the current
scripts sure and what they're giving you
to work with especially knowing that
Cavill is such a big Witcher fan and it
you know was like really gunning for
this role and how much he cares about
geralt definitely and you know the other
drama about like do the writers really
hate the books you know right right yeah
it's just yeah it makes it takes me out
of just being invested in the moment of
the show and makes me wonder things like
that yeah man oh well it's an odd odd
one but fun like you said this is fun
yeah I was I was
um
I didn't quite hit board yeah yeah so
nor was I like very entertained they're
like this is working this cookies is
really I was never like this is really
fun nor was I like I am bored out of my
mind right now no I was always intrigued
and I'm still willing to like root for
the show and give it the benefit of the
doubt yeah yeah
um
yeah I was I was like
um you know Henry Cavill the only time
I've never really dove into what anyone
was ever saying
um but the only talk I ever heard was
that oh Henry cavill's leaving
um because of how much they're straying
away from the material
and then watching this I was like
did Henry Cavill leave because
because it's just not as good anymore I
would not be at all surprised and the
thing is like I yeah like because I felt
like personally I thought season two as
a non-book reader
um for all books
[Laughter]
as a not as a non-liter reader of The
Witcher I thought it was a decent like I
still way preferred season one but I
thought it was a decent enough hybrid of
what they were wanting to achieve to
make it more attainable for audiences I
personally this is like whoa no this is
like three colonelitis just do the movie
version yeah yeah and and as a non-book
reader yeah it's that thing where you're
sitting there going I don't know the
source material but I bet it's not
exactly like this whereas like you watch
the first season you're like I don't
know but it feels again it feels
literary and then a I agree the second
season still maintains some of that and
this just feels like you know one of the
later Game of Thrones season where
they're just like just cut around you
know let's get some plots moving
yeah that was uh that was bumpy alrighty
guys well
sad part is I heard this is the best
episode of the season oh no could be
wrong maybe they're all boys willing to
disagree with with whatever opinions
I've heard
um I'm ready for a sleeper so yeah uh
surprised me with something great late I
don't know maybe this reaction series
will be just us bagging on the show now
um rage watch The Witcher
alrighty guys well before we go uh let
us know your thoughts and um let's send
this for the patreon
Brian
Perry you sound like this is perfect I
feel like Brian is like the elemental
version of this name this you know like
well-worn classic name and you know how
words and things warp over the years but
you're the original you're like the that
nugget that like you know little
Cornerstone of the sourdough that makes
the whole loaf over Generations after
Generations after Generations it was
prophesied
that all subsequent Brian's stem from
you you are the chosen one you are the
key we need your Elder blood Brian Perry
to uh both destroy and restore
everything you're the McGuffin of the
patreon and we appreciate you being here
and uh bringing us and chanting us each
month with your
unique Magic
love you buddy stay pledged toss a coin
to the patreon and we will not count it
matter how big the bag or small
as long as there's a bag we're happy
love you buddy till next time cheers
[Music]